ce que je sais c'est que le film qui
inquiète qui est vivant il n'est pas un
discours a vraiment choqué les gens et
d'une certaine façon que j'en suis
heureuse parce que c'est comme ça que
jean pierre est sorti de l'anonymat
allez grand père alors où es tu
vois tu vas pas me dire que tu as peur
de quelque chose où j'habite ici depuis
trente et un ans je suis dans un hlm de
la ville de caen je suis parfaitement
bien
alors ça s'appelle la pierre usée et cet
accord n'en calvados à 15 kilomètres du
village où je suis né qui s'appelle
bretteville l'orgueilleuse où était né
mon frère également bien sûr
[Musique]
m
e
sommes entrés dans la résistance par
tradition familiale ma mère était né
attention en 1885
elle avait donc bien connu la guerre de
14 et cette guerre et où elle a perdu
ses deux frères et son papa qu'elle
adorait et qui était officier de
gendarmerie
inutile de vous dire qu'on n'était pas
très germanophile chez nous mon frère
était tellement viciée de marine la
royale naturellement qu'ils étaient
interdites ou qu'il a fallu face et
courants marine marchande
mon père avait été sold eide avait été
coulé aux dardanelles parce qu'il était
officier mécanicien sur un sous marin il
a survécu mais ensuite il était blessé
indique ce monde
alors vous voyez la situation de la
famille voilà et très peu de temps après
nous avons eu l'occasion de rentrer dans
un réseau de résistance alors la
résistance en question que vous dire
pour moi alors que j'avais c'était du
travail de fourmi je les dis souvent
quand on me demandait de la d'experts
composé un papier à la mairie je
traversais la ville avec une nette à la
main je revenais avec la même dette
elle était un peu d par madame nerfs qui
savait parfaitement que je lui apportais
info et s'il n'était pas dû mais il n'ya
pas d'héroïsme là dedans je n'arrête pas
de répéter parce que nous avons commencé
à avoir peur
après l'arrestation de mme en phrases et
jean pierre a fait des choses beaucoup
plus dangereuse que moi et collecter des
armes ont été transportés des tracts
enfin oui il a fait des cheveux plus
dangereuse que moi alors
[Musique]
voilà ça c'est juste avant mon
arrestation
ça c'est les plus forts évidemment alors
voilà il dit que je suis belle
[Musique]
pourquoi avait déposé une gerbe de
fleurs pendant la guerre il était
formellement interdit sous peine de mort
de fleurir les tombes soient des
fusillés français soit des aviateurs
abattu comme les allemands par était
jean-pierre à cause de cette action là
c'est là qu'ils ont découvert leurs
raisons
c'est là que kalou et lecanu a été
arrêté aussi ils ont été arrêtés à cette
quoi est il en est revenu que deux
[Musique]
quelques temps après on a reçu ses
vêtements civils ce qui a plongé ma mère
dans une parfaite de l'esma où c'est ce
que ça veut dire
et en réalité d'autres jours après on a
reçu une lettre de la pwa rouge lui
disant qu'ils avaient été condamnés à
mort mais qu'en vertu de son jeune âge
ce avait été transformée en travaux
forcés à perpétuité
maintenant c'est ce que veut dire la
perpétuité
[Musique]
on était seul avec la petite lucie qui
était encore plus impressionné comme moi
parce qu'elle avait travaillé elle l'est
sur papier sur l'histoire de jean pierre
elle l'avait choisie parce que elle
avait 17 ans quand elle a commencé à
travailler sur son histoire et ses
larges où il a été arrêté
quant à moi par cette petite auprès de
moi quand je que je savait fragile quand
même 17 ans j'avais le besoin de la
sentir auprès de moi pour être sûr
qu'elle n'allait pas flanché et en fait
on met en même temps ça me donnait un
mois le courage de lassie on sait très
bien soutenu toutes les deux et dans les
recherches
on a trouvé qu'il dormait au bloc 7
avec ce document la paix
un tueur après l'entrée à thouars devant
le laisse le bronx qui n'est que du
treillage puisqu'on mais deux que des
cadavres dessus puis des cadavres qui se
vit forcément canucks se vide de son
pipi de cette matière donc c'est que de
la ferraille devant la porte du four là
c'est là que j'ai vu partir non pubères
ça je peux vous dire que la gelée vue là
je n'ai vu partir partir voilà je sais
oui c'était certainement le moment le
plus difficile je suis un peu dépassé
par l'horreur
est ce que tu te rends compte que
jean-pierre a fini là dedans
un grand bol d'or qui plaisait aux
filles
il était charmant
tu es brillant
je pardonne les oublie pas on ne pas
oublier tout ce que j'ai vécu
avant ça m'a permis de relativiser
beaucoup
pour résumer je veux dire par exemple je
suis une femme heureuse j'ai un toit sur
la tête j'ai pas froid j'ai pas faim
tout va bien
mon frère est mort sans couvertures par
terre sur une famille vous ne trouvez
pas que j'ai une situation où il ya
beaucoup
est ce que je sais c'est que le film qui
inquiète qui est vivant qui n'est pas un
discours vraiment choqué les gens et
d'une certaine façon que j'en suis
heureuse parce que c'est comme ça que
jean pierre est sorti de l'anonymat
à part quand je vous dis que le travail
qui l'attend ça se voit alors là c'est
dire
c'est l'antre du lion alors on y va
alors pour payer vous alors çà çà çà çà
çà et ça c'est le courrier qui vient
d'arriver
tous les jours je travaille je travaille
à peu près jusqu'à 3 heures du matin
pour éliminer donc si tous cas quand
même un peu changé votre fille colette a
pas du tout assure au bon dieu combien
d'un calcul on a dépassé les plus hauts
atteints
sarkozy son antre des messages les
courriers les accords
dans la jeunesse actuelle moi je
rencontre des jeunes vis aux garçons qui
sont vraiment des exceptions
intellectuelle avec des rigueur morale
avec des repères sérieux voilà mais je
trouve que c'est un un petit escadron
c'est pas un grand régiment c'est pas
une armée entière et aux français j'aime
les français on les connaît le nom donné
par notre professeur aux acteurs pour
leur voler ce qu'ils ont dans le crâne
alors c'est un espèce de coffres forts
on vous offre et les plains non parce
que c'est ma connaissance c'est de l'or
si vous le prenez pas vous faites
légalement partez vous en occupez pas ne
vous plaignez pas des poux
[Musique]